c'est la façon dont son cerveau coordonne ces informations complexes
entre les yeux et les ailes
et fait de la chasse un simple réflexe.
Pour étudier cela, Jaimie a passé beaucoup de temps
à fréquenter des libellules.
De quoi as-tu besoin pour tes expériences ?
Jaimie Saphr : Pour commencer, de libellules.
Oliver : J'ai un filet pour les attraper.
JS : Plus je travaillais avec elle, plus elles m'effrayaient.
Elles sont terrifiantes, surtout au microscope.
Elles ont des mandibules tranchantes, sont généralement agressives,
ce qui doit aussi les aider à être de très bonnes prédatrices.
GG : Pour découvrir ce qu'il se passe dans le cerveau de la libellule
à la vue d'une proie,
nous allons écouter une conversation
entre les yeux et les ailes
et pour cela, il faut anesthésier la libellule sur de la glace
et s'assurer de protéger ses ailes pour pouvoir ensuite la libérer.
Le cerveau de la libellule est fait de cellules spécialisées, les neurones,
et ces neurones permettent à la libellule
de voir et se déplacer si vite.
Les neurones forment des circuits en se connectant entre eux
via de longs fils fins appelés axones
et les neurones communiquent via ces axones avec de l'électricité.
Chez la libellule, nous allons placer de petits fils de métal, des électrodes,
le long des axones
et c'est la partie cool.
Chez la libellule, il n'y a que 16 neurones,
soit huit par œil,
indiquant aux ailes exactement où est la cible.
Nous avons placé les électrodes pour enregistrer l'activité des neurones
connectant les yeux aux ailes.
Quand un message est transmis de l’œil à l'aile,
notre électrode intercepte cette conversation
sous la forme d'un courant électrique
et l'amplifie.
Nous pouvons l'entendre et la voir sous la forme d'un pic
que nous pouvons appeler potentiel d'action.
Écoutons.
Actuellement, la libellule est retournée,
elle regarde donc vers le sol.
Nous allons prendre une proie ou ce que nous appelons une cible.
Dans ce cas, la cible va être une fausse mouche.
Nous allons la déplacer dans le champ de vision de la libellule.
(Bourdonnement)
Oh !
Oh, regardez.
Regardez, mais ce n'est que dans une direction.
Oh oui !
Vous ne voyez pas de pics quand j'avance,
ils sont tous quand je reviens.
Dans nos expériences,
nous avons pu voir que les neurones de la libellule
s'activaient en bougeant la cible dans une direction mais pas l'autre.
Pourquoi ?
J'ai dit que la libellule
avait une vision à près de 360 degrés.
Il y a une section de l’œil appelée fovéa,
qui est la partie ayant l'acuité visuelle la plus aiguë,
vous pouvez la voir comme un réticule.
J'ai dit que la libellule avait
un contrôle individuel et précis de ses ailes.
Quand une libellule voit sa proie, elle entraîne ses réticules dessus
et le long de ses axones, elle envoie des messages seulement aux neurones
contrôlant les parties des ailes
permettant de maintenir la libellule sur sa cible.
Si la proie est sur la gauche de la libellule,
seuls les neurones entraînant les ailes vers la gauche s'activent.
Si la proie se déplace vers la droite de la libellule,
ces mêmes neurones ne sont pas nécessaires et demeurent silencieux.
La libellule avance vers la proie
à un angle donné communiqué aux ailes par sa ligne de mire
et boum, elle a son dîner.
Tout cela se déroule en un instant et sans peine pour la libellule.
C'est presque comme un réflexe.
Et ce processus incroyablement efficace est appelé la fixation.
Mais il y a autre chose à dire sur ce processus.
Nous avons vu la réponse des neurones aux mouvements,
mais comment la libellule sait-elle que c'est une proie ?
C'est là que la taille compte.
Montrons à la libellule une série de points.
Oh oui !
JS : Elle préfère celle-là.
GG : De toutes les tailles,
nous avons découvert que la libellule répondait aux cibles plus petites.
Autrement dit, la libellule était programmée pour chasser de petits insectes
plutôt qu'une chose plus grosse comme un oiseau.
Dès qu'elle reconnaît une chose comme étant une proie,
ce pauvre petit insecte n'a plus que quelques secondes à vivre.
Nous avons vu comment le cerveau de la libellule
en fait une tueuse efficace.
Soyons reconnaissants de ne pas avoir vécu il y a 300 millions d'années
quand les libellules étaient de la taille des chats.